[Music]
on this saturday night the military's
new mission in saskatchewan the
reinforcements on the way as covet cases
climb those doctors and nurses they are
overwhelmed plus the unprecedented
measures the province is considering
pushing for a boost please from
indigenous communities for third doses
of the covet vaccine the dangerous risks
of ride sharing next thing i knew the
driver was
on top of me the troubling trend of
passengers being assaulted and a giant
puppet named little amal
the powerful message behind this
towering figure
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us ottawa is sending military aid to
saskatchewan to help that province fight
its fourth wave of the pandemic it's a
worrisome situation the cases of cova 19
are climbing and icus are so stretched
patients are being transferred to
ontario saskatchewan is now considering
entering a new phase of triage formally
outlining who gets potentially
life-saving care and who doesn't recent
modeling suggests that to bend the curve
the government needs to impose new and
more restrictions and as abigail beeman
reports that's not happening
yeah big catch
shopping for new gear ahead of musician
eric church's saskatoon stop the first
big show in saskatchewan since the
pandemic began i think we're all just
really excited to get out of the house
and yeah and all of us younger people
all got our vaccines so we could do this
you need proof of vaccination or a
negative covet test to get in there's
going to be like 13 14 000 people there
it's a little scary the concert is a
stark juxtaposition for doctors like
alex wong who have been advocating for
temporary public health measures like
indoor gathering limits
as the province's coveted rates climbed
to become one of the worst in this
country with 77 people filling icu's
patients continue to be transferred to
ontario this weekend up to three a day
expected to move early next week and of
the 288 people with coven 19 in
saskatchewan hospitals 72 percent are
not fully vaccinated the way out of the
pandemic is still vaccinations and we
all had hope that we would have higher
vaccination rates to reduce this ottawa
is promising help the prime minister
tweeting saskatchewan's we've got your
back the military is getting ready to
send up to six critical care nurses plus
help with patient transfers and
potentially backfill more nurses talks
are underway to send further help
including from the canadian red cross we
appreciate that something is coming in
now to help support those doctors and
nurses that definitely we see how much
they are overwhelmed the province is
also considering something they haven't
had to do before stage two of triage
formalizing the process of choosing who
gets care and who doesn't when there
aren't enough beds it's obviously
horrible i'm not sure that there's going
to be any realistic way that we're going
to be able to avoid that
because we just have too many people
coming in the canadian armed forces
expects to be on the ground in
saskatchewan until november 17 but say
they are prepared to stay longer if
necessary meanwhile next door in alberta
nine military nurses remain that help is
expected to wrap up next weekend abigail
beeman global news ottawa
starting monday saskatchewan will expand
its booster shop program to include
people living in the far north and in
first nations communities and now there
are growing calls for other provinces to
follow suit the council of the wet sweat
and first nation in northern bc issued
this statement demanding the province
immediately begin administering covet 19
booster shots to eligible members the
chief says two people have died in the
last two weeks and four elders have
recently tested positive for the virus
the request for assistance is being
echoed by the bc assembly of first
nations
the high infection rates is
really concerning to many first nations
communities and putting a lot of elders
at risk and this is the reason why we're
calling for a booster shot
terry tg says it has been around seven
months since many bc first nations
received their second dose
for the fifth straight day russia has
set a new record for kova 19 deaths in
the last 24 hours more than a thousand
people died from the virus that pushes
the country's official death toll past
229 000 the highest in europe russia has
dramatically low vaccination rates only
36 percent of the population is fully
vaccinated the government hopes to curb
the spread of the virus by bringing in a
nationwide paid week off later this
month
the countdown is on to the un's climate
summit better known as cop26 that's
where world leaders will try to find a
way to cut greenhouse gas emissions in
half by 2030. it's an aggressive target
and critics say canada is a long way
from meeting its own goals so what does
the government need to do
former environment minister catherine
mckenna has a solution michael couture
is hosting the west block this week mike
what is mckenna's agenda
robin even though she's out of politics
catherine mckenna is still very much on
the front lines of the climate fight
she'll be heading to cop 26 at the start
of november hoping to push for more
ambitious plans a part of that ambition
includes a 100 billion dollar annual
fund to support developing countries
tackle climate change that pledge is
more than a decade old but is a key
plank of the paris accord signed back in
2015. mckenna was at those talks as a
newly minted environment minister and
she says countries like canada need to
dig deep to achieve that goal otherwise
she says there will be no success at
this climate summit mckenna believes
canada can be a leader and an example
for other countries when it comes to
putting a price on pollution even though
reports say canada is not on track to
meet its emission reduction targets as
set out by the paris agreement the
trudeau government has set new and more
ambitious targets of reducing greenhouse
gas emissions by 40 to 45 percent by the
year 2030 and it's that kind of ambition
that mckenna feels is needed still the
former environment minister seems to be
lowering expectations going into the un
climate summit i mean look success
ultimately would look like we've got a
path to stay well below two degrees
striving for 1.5 i don't think we're
going to get there but the paris
agreement don't lose hope it requires
countries to continuously raise ambition
mckenna also said governments businesses
and individuals need to continue the
work in order to hit climate goals she
pointed to the covet 19 pandemic as an
example of how things can get done when
there's a global effort to tackle a
threat to us all
robin all right thanks mike and mike is
in for mercedes stevenson tomorrow
hosting the west block you can catch his
full interview with kathryn mckenna
sunday right here on global
saudi arabia one of the world's largest
oil producers says it plans to reach net
zero greenhouse gas emissions by 2060.
the announcement came at the first saudi
green initiative forum this new pledge
comes just days after documents leaked
to greenpeace revealed the kingdom asked
the u.n to downplay the need to reduce
the use of fossil fuels in an upcoming
climate report
turkey's president tayyip erdogan says
foreign ambassadors from 10 western
countries including canada are no longer
welcome in the country the expulsion of
the diplomats is in response to their
joint statement on monday demanding
jailed philanthropist and businessman
osman cavalla be released cavalla has
been in a turkish prison since 2017
charged with financing nationwide
protests in 2013 and accused of
launching a failed coup in 2016. erdogan
accuses the west of interfering in
turkey's judicial process
new details are emerging in the tragic
shooting on a new mexico movie set that
left a filmmaker dead court documents
reveal actor alec baldwin fired a prop
gun at a crew member after he was
assured it was safe in an affidavit
filed friday it states the film's
assistant director handed the weapon to
the actor during a rehearsal for the
movie rust and yelled cold gun declaring
the weapon didn't carry live ammunition
but that wasn't the case baldwin pulled
the trigger hitting a 40-year-old
cinematographer helena hutchins in the
chest
collies call hutchins a rising star
she just
radiated
a vibe
you know it's that like
x factor unknowable strange thing
director joel souza was also wounded
ex-crew members told the new york times
there were at least two accidental gun
discharges on set before this incident
the fatal shooting came just hours after
some workers walked off the job over
safety concerns
new data released by lyft shows the
company recorded thousands of assault
claims in just two years the
long-awaited report also revealed
details of multiple motor
vehicle-related deaths as reggie jacini
reports lawyers are circling in on
lawsuits
it was a report years in the making from
one of the two biggest ride sharing
companies looking into the safety of its
passengers lyft's got big
after pledging to release statistics in
2018 lyft made good on the promise on
thursday releasing data on so-called
safety incidents between 2017 and 2019.
the company reported 105 fatal
collisions and 10 fatal altercations
between drivers and passengers a
staggering drop in the bucket to the
more than 4 000 claims of assault 360
alone allegations of rape next thing i
knew the driver was
on top of me the findings are similar to
what uber made public in a 2019 report
however lyft says as rides increase
safety incidents are actually
increasingly rare at around point zero
zero zero two percent of all rides
that's almost four a day think about
that for a day steven este a san
francisco-based lawyer says his firm has
filed dozens of lawsuits against lyft
claiming ride-sharing companies can be a
breeding ground for predators it's a
place where you can go and work with
minimal background checks you have no
supervision
and you have access to vulnerable women
lyft argues that 99 percent of all trips
end without incident but for that small
percentage they faced lifelong
consequences someone who's been raped
and sodomized is going to deal with that
for the rest of their lives that's a
trauma that doesn't go away angela
nieman's law firm represents more than
one thousand americans who allege being
assaulted in a ride-sharing vehicle and
claims companies like lyft need to do
more to protect passengers they need to
accelerate the pace of the changes
they're making a lift spokesperson says
its goal is to make each lift ride as
safe as we possibly can
have an audio recording have a video
recording something and they will not do
that despite you know touting themselves
as a tech company primarily much like
uber lyft didn't include statistics for
canada despite having tens of thousands
of drivers and with more cases heading
to court victims hope it might bring
about long called for changes in the
name of safety
reggie chikini global news washington
coming up you may be paying more
interest on a loan than you realize
we'll explain when global national
continues
high interest loans have taken off
during the pandemic they allow canadians
with low credit scores to borrow large
sums of money but sometimes the interest
payments end up costing more than the
loan and gaviola explains
we were scared we didn't understand what
this disease was and is there
nobody knew nothing terrified during the
early days of the first coveted lockdown
65 year old kathleen zane took a leave
of absence from her call center job she
says she was unable to get a personal
loan from her bank which charges less
than eight percent annual interest but
she already had a high interest loan of
fifteen hundred dollars with easy
financial which she increased to five
thousand still in an annual interest
rate of thirty percent it was
such a relief off my mind
because i was like what the hell am i
gonna do this summer she says she was
shocked to see how much interest she was
being charged i thought oh my god i've
been ripped off
in an email to global news go easy the
parent company of easy financial said it
provides a copy of the full loan
agreement to every customer immediately
after signing and walks the customer
through key elements of the loan
including interest rate and total cost
of borrowing its customers are
hardworking everyday canadians that have
typically been turned down by banks and
traditional lenders global news also
interviewed people with installment
loans similar to kathleen's from money
mart which is not affiliated with easy
financial it did not receive a response
from moneymart we found that a lot of
the the payday lenders and the
installment loan companies are taking
advantage of the situation because they
know people are desperate for money
anti-poverty group acorn says
installment loans have taken off during
the pandemic in 2020 they were 300 times
more popular than in 2016. payday loans
can be a quick fix for those in need of
cash but the price is a heavy interest
penalty although payday loans charge a
lot more in interest installment loans
which are also offered by many payday
lenders are typically much larger sums
of money the liberal platform includes a
line pledging to crack down on predatory
lenders by reducing the criminal rate of
interest which currently stands at 60
percent now many of these installment
loans charge about half of that acorn
wants to see the criminal rate of
interest to come down to 30 percent to
target installment loan patricia edwards
turned to money mart for high interest
loans to help with cash flow she says
she needs to borrow money to pay for
transit to be able to get to work or to
cover rent before her paycheck comes in
it's an endless cycle it's like
being in a tornado
and you're just whirling around month
after month the high interest makes it
hard to get ahead she's been trying for
years and gaviola global news
a fire has broken out on a docked ship
that lost 40 containers off the coast of
b.c the situation on board is still
unclear but the canadian coast guard
says a safety vessel is standing by on
thursday the ship hit rough seas near
vancouver island causing dozens of cargo
containers to go overboard boaters are
being warned there's a risk of hitting
drifting cargo
still ahead the reality bending
technology that could be the future of
workspaces
[Music]
over 50 years after humans first stepped
on the moon nasa is going back the
agency will launch its orient space
shuttle in february it will orbit the
moon and then return to earth but there
won't be a crew on board nasa says it
will pave the way for a future test
flight with astronauts on board the goal
is to have boots back on the lunar
surface by 2024
back on earth a canadian aerospace
company is making giant leaps despite
being grounded by the pandemic engineers
have found a way to train astronauts in
the u.s to operate groundbreaking space
technology they've created virtual
workspaces through augmented reality
jeff sample looks at whether it's a sign
of things to come for the rest of us
for the first time since the pandemic
jessa marie zabala is back in her office
so we're right through here because of
the dreamer lab the systems engineer
works at mda for 40 years the ontario
aerospace company has trained astronauts
to operate the canadarm building five
generations of the canadian made robotic
arm used on space shuttles and the
international space station but when the
pandemic hit the team was grounded
unable to conduct its training
that is until zabala's team had an idea
that seemed out of this world
a lot of us have spent the pandemic
sitting at our desks interacting with
our colleagues over zoom but some
emerging technology is now altering that
reality
prior to the pandemic zabala had
experimented with augmented reality
headsets they project holograms across a
physical space going to work is so
different like you roll out of bed and
you put on a headset
today trainers in brampton work
alongside flight controllers in montreal
and astronauts in houston all
interacting in the same virtual space
hi susan
hi
zabala's colleagues appear as avatars
basically floating heads that mimic
their actual movements
you get that experience of like oh you
hear them right next to you on like this
side this felt like a real conversation
mixed reality tech has been adopted by a
range of industries from surgeons and
auto mechanics to canada's oldest candy
company when a piece of equipment at new
brunswick's genong factory breaks down
the manufacturer used to send someone
often overseas but in the pandemic they
started connecting and assisting
virtually we are seeing a a big uptake
here in terms of using this technology
this work culture consultant helps
businesses adopt new technologies he
says the pandemic drove companies to
innovate and look for alternatives to
the traditional if tedious video
conferences i think that right now as
you think about hybrid work and remote
work we're looking at technologies like
mixed reality
is a way to make that experience feel
which is much more immersive i
spend my meetings in space
one small step for the aerospace
industry one giant leap for the future
of work
jeff semple global news brampton ontario
and jeff further explores the future of
work by delving into how innovative
companies are investing in their
employees that's on the new reality
tonight at seven right here on global
up next the bc man who cycled 50 days
for mental health and the kind strangers
that kept it going
little amal which means hope in arabic
has traveled 8 000 kilometers to the uk
the giant puppet of a refugee girl left
turkey in july trekking across europe to
raise awareness of the difficulty
refugee children face along the way
there was a visit with the pope a strong
supporter of migrant rights
one in four canadians has symptoms of
depression anxiety or ptsd that's
according to a recent national survey a
fundraiser called ride don't hide is
raising money for people struggling with
mental health and isolation an abc man
set out on a solo ride from the 49th
parallel to the arctic ocean for the
cause as jay durant explains he says he
never felt alone
to raise money and awareness for mental
health mikey friedland decided to go for
a little bike ride his trip took him
from the canada u.s border in a soo used
to tuck the yuck duck on the arctic
ocean i didn't have any training i
planned this about three weeks before i
started and i learned as i as i went he
was on his own no car following behind
him sometimes camping at the end of the
day hello or staying in remote off the
grid cabin this is amazing
i'm in the middle of nowhere
and it is hailing on me but what makes
this adventure so special is even though
he was on his own he was never really
alone random strangers would offer him
help along the way he stopped to give me
water
and
fried chicken man some roadside meals
and snacks to help him through his ride
as i was patching my tire a man stopped
and offered me some hard-boiled eggs
friedland admits he had no idea what to
expect out there it was these
connections with the people he met that
completely
of this land i had help from dozens of
strangers
uh you know and including you know
canadians of
of of all backgrounds this is a very
narrow shoulder
after nervous moments on some highways
not very biker friendly rock slides
impeding his path
oh man
that's easy there he is bears mosquitoes
rain wind and exhaustion he finally
reached the finish line after 50 long
days of cycling
so far he has raised over thirty
thousand dollars and is still collecting
for canadian mental health his own
struggles during the pandemic pushing
him towards this epic journey filled
with so many little victories along the
way
i'm trying to take into my life off of
the bicycle is create all of these these
moments where i can i i can get that
that satisfaction and that that
feeling of accomplishment and self-worth
jay durant global news
well done and that is global national
for this saturday night i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is this duck
enjoying the mirror river in nova scotia
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]